Welcome to Ear Biscuits, the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
Sometimes a really long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at The Round
Table Of Dim Lighting
is the second part of our podcast.
The conversation that we just finished.
That we recorded last, that
you listened to last week,
but we sat down and we recorded
it all at the same time.
Basically what happened
as we indicated last week
is that we were having a
conversation about board games,
and I brought up my
repeated accusation of Link,
which is that I feel that he
is just as competitive as me,
and that opened a huge can of worms about,
pooh, man, it just got, it got deep.
And I don't know exactly
when Kiko is gonna decide,
so what we're about to play
for you in the conversation,
it might overlap a little bit,
it might backtrack a little bit
with where last week's ended
before we cut in, I don't know.
Kiko, how you are gonna do this?
But I think this is an
important conversation.
And I think it will make
you feel better to know
that we've had this conversation already
that you're about to listen to,
and everything is okay.
Yeah, we're still good.
We are okay, it got kind of
intense in a couple of places,
but I think it was a good conversation.
I'm glad that it happened.
I don't know how you're
going to interpret it,
but as we said at the end of last week,
as you interact with this
conversation, as you listen to it,
and then as you talk about it online,
we would just ask that in the spirit
that we tried to embody,
as we had the discussion,
which is a spirit of
goodwill, I would say.
It's like we said some
hard things or whatever,
but the whole point of this is,
it's not for it to become some competition
between the two of us where you're like,
well, I think that Rhett was right
or I think that Link was right or...
How can we be illuminating in the way
that we continue the conversation, right?
How can you be illuminated?
How can we all understand each other more?
Yeah, and what does this make
you think about yourself?
Not just what you think
about one or both of us,
but like how do you relate
to some of the things
that we're seeing and what does
it make you think about your
own personal journey and the
way that you see the world?
And maybe this is, I mean,
maybe this is the end of the conversation,
but it's the beginning
of the conversation.
And I'm not talking about this episode.
I don't know, I'm just,
I don't know how much it like.
I mean, I-
I just wanna talk about it.
We made it sound like this is crazy.
Yeah, I don't think it's crazy.
We built it up too much.
Yeah, we built it up.
It's just a conversation about board games
became a conversation about our friendship
and the way that we view
the interplay between the two of us.
Well, just, and here it is,
and now you can listen to it.
Here it is.
Ultimately everybody wants to be
important in some way, right.
And people who are in
entertainment kind of achieve that
and find their purpose a lot of times in,
eliciting a reaction from people.
And I would say that you are
actually even more focused
and committed to getting
a reaction from a crowd
or from a individual than I am.
You think about like
the way that your super,
I'm much less concerned about things like,
where is this thing and
where is the camera,
and I'm not showing,
I'm not opening this box in the right way.
In my mind, that's all competitive nature.
It's like you have a
commitment to excellence,
and you're thinking about
competitiveness in like,
I'm throwing a ball faster
than a person or not,
but you actually care about
that stuff more than I do.
And I would call that sort of,
I would almost say it's
a relentless pursuit
of doing things in a certain way.
Perfection is not, I mean-
I interpret that as-
Is attained by comparison
to like a standard.
Yes.
But I think it's a stretch to
say that that's competition,
like I'm competing against the standard.
Now I also think this is,
I think it's a little muddied by,
I don't know.
Do you get from me in
this conversation that
like I judge you for being competitive?
Yes.
That, and I think, that's interesting
because I think that's
really what's going on
is that your counterpoint
is you feel judged
by me for being competitive.
I think what-
And so then you're trying to put it on me.
And I hear you say is that like-
Hey man, I just don't.
I am superior-
I don't.
Because I'm not competitive.
I don't bother with like wanting to win
a stupid game for
somebody, that's kind of-
But I don't believe that,
I don't believe that.
I think you're, I just, I
don't think that's happening.
And I guess, and what I'm saying,
so that's part of it, but I also what I'm,
one of the things I'm saying is that
I feel like our entire career
is based on a competition ultimately.
I think there's a
competition against ourselves
and against our like,
looking back on something
that we did and not liking
it and wanting to do better.
Well, but seeing that as a competition is
because you're a competitive person.
I just don't,
like we're not competing
against ourselves trying to-
But we're also constantly
competing against each other.
So you're saying like-
That's part of it as well.
It's like, you think about the way
me and you like to divide
everything up like,
so, all right, we're
gonna do this meeting,
so you're gonna say these things
and I'm gonna say these things,
don't say more than me,
and we're both equally committed to that.
And so if you think.
I just don't think I view
that as a competition, but-
But what is it if it's not a competition?
It's something that I care about deeply,
that's a different thing that,
again, I'm not judging you if
you see it as a competition.
Well, if it's not a competition-
But I don't, but that's just the,
that's the way you look at the world.
And when you see me act
in the way that you would,
again, I think it's something different,
like me being a perfectionist
to a flawed point, absolutely.
Like I could be defensive
about like, yeah, I'm,
I think about how I open
boxes like whatever you are,
I know exactly what you're talking about.
Well, I'm saying that I think that that,
and I don't think that's
a bad thing ultimately
is what I'm saying.
I think that that is a sign of someone.
But I'm saying there are things about me,
like I'm a perfectionist,
just like you could say,
I'm a competitive person.
Let's just, and I'm saying,
well, there were flaws
associated with that,
but I'm not putting that on,
I'm not judging you being competitive.
I'm saying the only thing,
I guess I was insinuating
was sometimes when you're not competitive
and you're around competitive people,
it doesn't, it's not a good time,
but that's not a judgment on that,
because you're a bad person.
Yeah, I think what I am saying is,
I mean, I think that is part of it,
but I think what I'm saying is that
my understanding of the
competitive spirit is something
that I think that there are
elements of your personality
that are based in a competitive spirit.
Yes, that's true.
And much more than you
give yourself credit for it
because I don't think it's
a bad thing, right, because,
and whether you want to
use the term 'competitive'
or not, but it's just like,
and I think that the competition,
and I don't mean the staged competition,
but in every relationship, every marriage,
every creative partnership,
there is healthy competition.
If there is not healthy competition,
then it's just one person
just doing everything
and getting their way, but that isn't,
that isn't the nature of our partnership.
It's just like I fight for
ideas, you fight for ideas.
You have things that are important to you,
I have things that are important to me,
and we fight for those things, right.
And the creative process is,
is based in a competitive spirit, I think.
For you.
I think for me, I want things
just as badly as you do
and for good reasons and bad reasons,
but I just don't, I don't look,
I don't look at that through
a lens of competition
as readily as you do.
And I look through a different lens
depending on what the example is.
And I just think that's how
we see things differently
and things resonate with us differently.
Like the more something
is overtly competition,
the more I am going to shrink from it,
and the more you are
going to engage with it.
I think that's the definition.
To me that's the definition
of, are you competitive person?
When you're faced with some
of this obviously competitive,
how do you respond?
And, again, with no
judgment attached to that.
Yeah, I get that.
Yeah, I think it's very simply that
I see it as broader than that.
Like I think that even
like we talked about this for years,
like when we, when me and you are,
like when we're performing,
it's just like, are you tell...
I refuse to believe that there
is not something in your mind
because we've talked
about it a million times.
Like if we're watching
an edit of something
that is more like, we
went out and did something
and now we're editing it.
Sure, we balance.
We wanna balance,
but we were not trying
to achieve that balance
just in the name of brand.
It's just like, I'm fully ready.
I'm fully willing to
admit that it's just like,
I want to be able to watch that video
and think I contributed to
the comedy in this video,
like I got some good lines in there.
And if I watch a video, I'm like,
man, I didn't really get to
express myself in the way
that I would like to.
If I could go back and
engineer this video,
it would be like a 50:50
thing whereas you know what,
Link got a bunch of good one
liners in there in this video,
and now, so for me, I'm
saying that there is a,
what I think is ultimately
a healthy competition.
It's not like, oh, I want
to get more than Link.
I don't want Link to say anything funny
because that would be like.
Yeah, I just don't call that competition.
So what is it if it's not?
Because I would think if you could,
I don't view that as comp.
First of all, we agree
in what we're after.
Like we talk about balance a lot,
but the way that I
think, like I just don't,
I don't think I think about
it in terms of competition.
I think about it in terms of pulling,
pulling my weight or contributing.
What I'm saying is personal though.
I think ultimately I'm saying is that,
it is personally motivated.
It isn't like I'm trying to meet,
it's not like you're
trying to meet an external
quota of like, we've decided
in some times long past
that we are 50:50 contributing
to as much as possible,
but it's like in the moment
when you're watching a video
and you're like, I'm trying to get,
I want to be an equal partner in this,
I think there's an element of
competition that's based on
you're an advocate for yourself
in a non-prideful, healthy way.
In other words, like if I were to go in
and edit a video without you being there
and you were like, man, I
said a bunch of funny things
and he's edited those things
out when I wasn't there.
You would be...
Would you be personally offended?
And would you be offended
because we're not meeting some standard
or would you be personally offended
because, hey, man, I
said some funny things
and I want the world to
know about those things.
Yeah, I would be offended because,
but I wouldn't be like because
I wanna beat you, to me that-
I'm not talking about beating.
Right, but see, that's how
I think of competition.
I think of
this example is not competitive.
It's like, I mean,
we're both, if we've had
times when we've thought
I want to be seen as
funnier than the other guy,
then I think that's probably
not a healthy level of competition.
My instinct is that,
I just don't look at it
through a lens of competition,
because I don't, it
doesn't feel healthy to me.
No, but what is,
but if you're an advocate for yourself
and there's a pie with a
limited amount of contribution,
and I'm the other person
who is contributing to it,
then what is it if it's,
I guess I don't think it's a bad thing.
I agree with you that it would be bad
if it was just like we, either
of us had a secret agenda
to belittle the other guy,
but for me a lot of times
what happens is just this like,
like we might do a live show, right,
and I'm like, like we go out and I'm like,
we've done the show that
night, and I'm like, man,
I didn't bring a lot tonight.
Yeah.
Right, but I'm also
I'm thinking about it in,
the only other person
on stage is you, right.
And so naturally I'm gonna be like,
well, I didn't bring a lot tonight,
Link did bring a lot tonight.
So when I think tomorrow
night, I want to bring a lot,
not to be better than him,
but so that it will even out.
And so, but in doing
that I am, there is a,
I am personally, I'm motivated.
I know, but you're not trying to beat me.
So you're thinking the same thing,
I think those same things
too is like, man, I didn't,
the way I think about it as,
man, I didn't pull my weight.
I didn't, I'm glad that
Rhett stepped up or,
because then it would, if
he had a bad night too,
then that would have sucked.
I mean, I think of
episodes of GMM that way.
It's like, oh man, I just,
if I didn't pull my weight,
hopefully you pulled more or-
But really there's that all it is
because what if every single time
you didn't pull your weight,
I pulled more weight.
And what if it that was the standard?
And what if it was
like, man, it's kind of-
Well, I-
That would bother you,
but why would it bother you?
Or you're saying, it won't bother you?
The times when I feel
like I don't perform well
and you do perform well,
like in a given episode
or a given thing, does that bother me?
Does it bother you in a
single instance, but does it,
what if that became the
pattern, would that bother you?
And what part of you would it bother?
It would absolutely bother me,
it absolutely does bother
me when it happens,
but I feel like I direct
all of that towards myself.
I don't look at it through
a lens of competition.
Oh, I direct it towards myself completely,
but the person, but the only
other person contributing
to the mathematical equation
by which I judge myself is you.
I mean, I certainly compare
myself to you all the time,
and I reached certain conclusions.
I think, and I know that there's a healthy
when we're both at our best.
I think, I guessed.
It's a-
I'm trying to get you to...
What I'm trying to do is I,
like, okay, we can use a different word
if you don't like the word
'competitive,' but like, okay.
Well, that's what we're
talking about though.
Let's say, I'm just saying,
I call that competition.
You're right, and that's my point exactly.
Okay.
We both know-
Let's say, I come to work.
We both know how this works
to make it the best it can be.
All right, I think I got
you, I think I got you.
I think I'm about to get you
because you can disagree with me.
Okay.
But let's say that we go to-
I think you're being competitive now
because you're not gonna
quit until I agree with you.
No, I just want you to acknowledge.
I want you to acknowledge.
You want to win-
No, no, no.
This argument.
No, no.
I'm trying to get you to-
That I'm competitive too.
To accept something that
I think is true about you.
Okay, hit me with it.
So let's say-
Okay, we're going on Fallon,
we both get suits for Fallon.
Okay.
When you think about what
you're wearing, right?
Yes.
And you think, okay-
Who looks better?
Let's say we go on Fallon and
like we come off of Fallon,
and then we start looking on the internet
and what people are saying and like,
everyone is talking about
how awesome my suit is.
They're not saying, they
might even be saying it like,
what happened with Link's suit?
but like Rhett's suit is on fire tonight.
Like, Link, you already wore
that suit, that happened.
Does that bother you?
Yes.
So in the sense of wanting
to have a cool suit,
but what I'm saying is,
you don't exist for better or for worse,
neither of us exist in
this world of entertainment
as our own entity, we are
tied to the other guy.
We don't do solo projects
where I'm not off doing
things, you're not.
When we present ourselves, we
present ourselves as a duo,
and like we both are like, I'm,
it's like when they come
and they start fitting,
like if we're getting ready to get fitted
for like one of these things,
and like, they're like,
here's all your options, Link,
and here's all your options, Rhett.
And I like look at your options,
I'm like, man, he's got a
lot better options than me.
You know what, he's six feet tall,
he's not six foot seven, I get it,
it's really hard to find
things for a tall guy,
but damn, I wish, I wish they
would bring me cool suits too.
I think that's competition.
I think the net result of that,
now it could get really
unhealthy if it was just like,
I want more people to like
me then than like Link.
That's not at all what I'm after,
but I want people to be
like, they look good,
those suits look good, and
that may be a shallow thing,
but I don't want it to be like,
man, I went out there in
this frumpy bad fitting suit,
Link looks really sharp, like that,
I have a problem with
that personally, right.
I want us both to look good.
And so I think that when I'm
looking at your rack of suits,
there's a competition there.
The ultimate thing is if
you're focused on that,
which my premise is, you're
just as focused on that as I am,
maybe even more when it comes
to certain things, right.
Then the net result will be like,
we both wanted this to come out right,
and the net result is
both of us wanting that
in a healthy way, the
net result was as good as
it was the best possible result.
You didn't pick a good example
because I mean what happens
with suits if we're talking,
because it's a good example in that,
it's the most superficial
thing that we do.
Right, it's incredibly superficial.
It's the most, you're
right because it's like
we have to coordinate
whatever we're gonna wear,
so that like it doesn't clash.
And we both know that we both wanna look,
we want us together as a duo
to look as good as possible.
But what if I was gonna
have a little cool light
on my shoulder, and I was like,
I got this thing on the
suit that it lights up
and it like a hologram projects
my name over my shoulder.
You'd be like, well, I want one of those.
First of all you haven't-
If you thought it was a good idea.
I feel like you're more competitive
when it comes to this than I am.
This one I think is a bad example,
but you have a chip on your shoulder
because your shoulder
is so tall in the air,
you're six foot seven,
you have trouble getting
clothes that fit you.
So I'd say, you know what,
every single time we do this,
the system is you go and you try on,
you pick out whatever it
is works best for you,
and then I will come in and then you say,
okay, this is the best
that they've got for me.
It's frustrating because
this is all they could find
to fit a man as big as me.
Right.
And then I'm like, okay, then I have,
then I will work around your choices.
But you resent that a little bit.
And I will.
Just a little bit.
You keep your arguments floating.
No, no, no, I'm just, I feel like-
I don't know what your point is.
I feel like you're trying to say
that you don't have any
personal pride, and I think,
and I'm saying healthy,
good, personal pride,
and I think you do and
there's nothing wrong with it.
And I think that you-
I've said that I care.
If everybody complimented
you on your suit,
nobody complimented me on my suit,
that would hurt my feelings.
Especially if you had to
overlook a cool-ass suit
because I had to wear another
suit because I'm tall.
Yes.
You'd be like,
man, if I had the other suit on right now,
if this dumbass wasn't so tall,
I'm just saying that like that-
But it's not.
And I'm not saying that's,
I'm just saying I don't have
a problem with that like-
I'm just saying, I don't,
do I think about that in terms
of competition, is he better?
I mean, when you get into comparison,
is comparison competition?
I'm just, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying, yes, it is,
and I think that in the
context of any relationship,
it's healthy because if-
I think here's the difference.
I do think that, and again,
this is on a spectrum.
It is not you're one way, I'm another way,
but like you have a tendency,
you have more of a tendency
to look at something
as a competition meaning
only one person can win,
then can't we all just be equal?
Can't we both just be equal?
I think that I feel differently
about it than you do.
I think I just,
I instinctively look
through a different lens.
But what, I guess what
I don't understand is
what the lens is?
Because if you were saying that I don't,
actually you care about that,
and again, this is, I do
feel judged by that, right,
because what I hear you saying is that,
you got to understand,
you care about that,
you wanna look good or
you wanna seem funny.
I'm open to having-
But I don't.
An equally flawed lens,
it's just a different one.
And what I'm saying is, I
think that you want to be,
you want to express yourself and be unique
and be perceived in a certain way
just like most healthy,
well-adjusted people do.
Yes.
And I think you want that.
I think you want it just as much as I do.
Now, but yeah, when we get into like-
I agree with that, I agree with that.
We're both, like I am no
less flawed than you are.
No, I don't think it's flawed.
I'm not saying it's a bad thing.
I think the thing that is
frustrating for me trying to-
Being competitive is not a flaw,
but there's flaws associated with it.
I feel like there's,
what I feel you saying,
not hear you saying, but feel you saying
is that there is something
wrong with admitting
that you want some attention.
And it would be wrong,
so competing for attention,
whatever the word might be, right.
And what I'm saying is that in
an entertainment partnership,
there are certain partnerships
where they kind of came
to some agreement like Penn
and Teller, right, well-
One of them is not gonna talk.
Could you be the guy that didn't talk?
Hell, no, and neither could
I, but that's not who we are.
And what I'm saying is, yes, it could get,
if it was unhealthy, then we
wouldn't still be best friends
and business partners.
Like we have a
unprecedented friendship and
business relationship, right?
Like even more so than your typical
other comedic duos out there,
you got like Key and Peele,
like yeah, they made a
show together and stuff,
but like how often do they see each other?
How often are they
working together, right?
And probably not much at all right now.
And I'm not saying that
you're not gonna go
and do something by yourself
or I'm gonna do something
that I'm passionate about, whatever,
but I think that, I think the argument
that I'm trying to make
is that there is something
healthy about the friendly,
healthy competition
between the two of us.
And I'm using the term 'competition,'
you wanna say self-comparison,
self-measuring,
whatever the word you wanna use
that ultimately I think is a benefit
and is a positive thing,
but I feel you talking
about it in a way as if
you would be ashamed to admit
that that was a dynamic.
And I'm just saying,
and maybe I'm really ready to admit it,
just because it does for me,
I'm competitive in many other areas.
And so, I just naturally
map that onto to this,
but I don't see the,
but the way I see this different is
I'm not trying to win anything.
I'm not trying to
be better, get more attention.
I'm just trying to make sure that I get,
that we are getting to that
50:50 when we do things,
and it doesn't always happen.
And again, I think I'm
defining a competitive spirit
as wanting to win, to outdo, it's not-
Yeah, and that's not
what I'm talking about.
Then that's not competition.
I think you're not using a good example.
I think we both know that like
we are at our best when we
enable each other's best,
like we don't, we are not
at our best independently.
Right.
We are at our best corporately.
And so, if us being at our best is
like we both not talking all the time.
It's like, we couldn't
hear anything anyone said,
if we both talked all the time
or we both listened to all the time,
it is just a dumb example,
I just don't feel like that's-
I think I have a difference of opinion
about that because-
I define being a competitive
person is wanting to win.
And then when you bring,
if you were to bring
that mentality into this,
I mean, it's like, you just,
again, it's just a, you like to win
and you like to achieve
things, and that's good,
but it's just a lens
that you bring to this.
And we have a healthy,
creative relationship,
but we look through different lenses.
And I guess I don't
understand what your lens is
because what I'm saying is, like if we,
so like when we're writing Buddy System,
and it's like, okay, we've
got this really funny
sort of one off role that
we've invented for you,
my natural instinct is to be like,
okay, what's the one-off funny
role that I'm gonna play?
All right, Link is to do
this quirky cave deal,
so I'm gonna be the bike or
something like that like.
Yeah.
To me, I'm just saying, I
am being vulnerable here,
but I'm readily admitting
that there is a
competitive element to that
because if I was like, you know what
because even if you would be
better at being this and this,
I still would make the
decision to advocate
for myself to be this and you to be that,
not just because it makes sense
from a Rhett and Link brand,
yeah, that's part of it, but also because,
oh, I wanna also have a funny,
I want to be a funny guy.
I want to play the quirky role.
And to me, are you saying
that that is not true of you?
It's true for me, but the
equation is different,
like I think the first
thing I think of is like,
I wanna contribute, I want to be,
I wanna pull my weight and I want to,
I don't know, I guess I
don't want to be seen,
it's like I don't want
to be seen as a loser
as like the hanger on.
Well, that's-
Like, but so it's, again,
it's the same thing.
It's a different, it's almost like
the negative viewpoint of the same thing.
It's like, if you're saying I wanna win,
then I'm saying, well, I don't wanna lose.
Yeah, that's all I and I-
Right, so I-
And I'm just saying that because I felt-
Right.
Like I was going crazy.
Not that you were like gas-lighting me,
but I felt like I was going crazy
because what I hear,
like what I hear you saying is,
you think those things in
the context of what we do,
but I don't really think those things,
but what I hear you saying now
is, I do think those things,
I think about them differently
maybe through a different
lens, but in practice,
when I look at something like a script,
I immediately look at,
whoa, there's my name
and there's my lines,
there's his name and there's his lines,
let's make sure those are even.
Yeah.
And I feel like us wanting that
is coming from the same place,
it's coming from a personal,
you're a personal advocate,
but I think that that's healthy.
I don't think, it can become unhealthy
if it was, I want to dominate,
I want to see my name more,
that's a problem.
If you write a script, you
take that into account.
You take balance into account,
you're not just, you're
not trying to make,
you're not trying to
make just you look good
if you write something, I
mean, if I edit something,
I'm not just trying to make me look good,
I'm trying to make us look good.
And so we differ.
And often I might actually
bias something towards
you having a little bit more.
You know what I'm saying?
Like because if it's a
certain kind of thing
that I'm writing and I'm
spending more time on it,
well, I don't wanna be the
asshole who like is also,
well, I'm in control
of this at this stage.
Yeah.
And so I'm going to like
write more for myself.
Like I actually, I
think I do the opposite,
but I'm just saying the element, the fire,
the spark of being your own advocate
and how that takes place in
the context of our friendship
and the context of our,
is mostly the context of
our creative partnership
because our whole business is based on
people finding us likable
and enjoyable and funny,
and wanting to sit on
and listen to us talk.
Yeah, I mean, I don't,
and I'm just trying to process honestly,
and I do think that like,
I don't try to make you look like a jerk
in these conversations, I think you-
Well, you do sometimes,
but I know you're not trying to.
I know that, I know you
feel like that happens.
Honestly, I just,
I feel like I operated not
out of a desire to win,
but out of a desire not to fail.
It's just a different motivation.
I think there's a difference.
It's a different motivation.
And so it doesn't feel like-
But I'm just saying,
I think that comes from the same place.
I think it comes from the same
place in a person wanting to-
Well, I think it come-
You got some personal pride.
I think it...
Okay, yeah.
Because there are some people who aren't,
what I'm getting at is
there a lot of people
who are not like that.
Yeah, there's pride.
I don't wanna look, like I said,
I don't wanna look stupid,
I don't wanna look a loser,
I don't wanna look like
I'm not pulling my weight,
I don't want to be seen as a sidekick.
And also, and this is why I
use the term 'competition'
because there is an
intensity to it, right.
In the midst of a performance,
in the midst of us going
out and doing like,
we don't do this a whole lot anymore
because we don't go out,
but like when we were like
shooting The Backup Plan
where it's like, all right,
we're gonna go into this situation,
we're gonna interact with this person
or commercial kinks, whatever,
we both are like, I'm
gonna try to be funny.
And it's like, whoa, if
you ramp up and it's like,
man, he's really knocking it
out of the park right now,
I'm like, I got to get up to that,
I gotta get up to that place.
To me the net result of that is,
well, it's twice as funny
as it would have been,
but there's a lot of people who is like,
man, he's really popping off right now,
and he's really being funny,
who would shrink down.
And what I'm saying is, and
ultimately it may sound,
this is a backwards way to get to it,
I'm trying to compliment you.
And I'm just trying to get
you to accept the compliment
is that I think that you
are an equal advocate
for yourself to the degree that I am,
but that you have a
little bit of a problem
with accepting that.
You don't wanna accept
that you're an advocate for
yourself to a large degree.
I'm not trying to diagnose
you, I'm just saying that like,
my perception of
interacting with you is that
you want it just as much as I do.
You want whatever it is we're
trying to get as much as I do.
And that's a good thing,
and if you didn't,
then we wouldn't be here.
And so, but there's a
part of me that's like,
you don't wanna be perceived
as a guy who really wants it.
I'll let him be the one that
seems like he really wants it.
Well, first of all, I'm not
making a play on this podcast
to be perceived in a certain way.
Yeah-
I'd never thought,
so that's not what's happening that like,
that dynamic of what happens or what,
I don't know, that's another conversation
for what happens on this podcast sometimes
where it's like, I feel like
we both want the same things,
but we don't have the exact same drive.
It's not the same chemical makeup
because we're different people.
But you're just as driven as me.
That's all
I am driven, but I don't,
you've made it very personal.
And I think it complicates it
because if you go back to
like just the simple things
like what kind of sports do you like?
There's a,
I think we can easily
agree that you enjoy things
that are competitive,
like cardboard competitive
much more than me.
Yeah, and I think this
gets at the root of a big,
this, I think I have an issue.
And then you funnel that back into.
Well, no, I think I have an issue with,
there's so many people who are like,
I don't like sports because
I'm not competitive,
but then I'm like, well, look
what you do for a living.
Like I have somebody I
know who is a musician
and is very committed to their art
and wants to be good at it
and is incredibly driven,
but it's like, I don't really like sports,
I don't get it, it seems like
I just, I'm not competitive,
I'm not into competitive things,
I'm like, boy, he sure as hell.
But you know that I don't judge sports,
so just lose that for a second.
Like I don't look down on
anybody who screams at a screen
about sports, I don't.
I guess what I'm saying is
that I think more people than,
and I'm not, and again,
this can come across like
I'm trying to, and again, I understand.
Yes, I do think there
is a dynamic sometimes
where we get into a conversation like this
and I'm being, what I
perceive as being vulnerable,
which is like, I'm kind of pulling back
the curtain on my mind and
it's like, oh, he's kind of,
things get a little
dark in there sometimes.
And I perceive in those
moments you trying to be like
distance yourself from that and be like,
well, that's not, I'm not like that.
I mean, you're like that,
but I'm not like that.
And I guess I'm selfishly trying to say,
well, not just to make myself feel better,
but to make myself feel sane.
It's difficult for me to
interpret your actions
over the course of our lifetime
through the lens of you
not being competitive
in the broadest sense.
I know you're not competitive
when it comes to sports
and even most games, but I'm saying,
I think you're competitive
when it comes to life.
And I think that most people,
even the most humble among us
who wanna do something meaningful
and impactful in the world.
In fact the primary
motivation of most people
on Earth is to be important,
And I think that there's
nothing wrong with that,
it's basically deeply built into our DNA.
And I'm just saying, I'm saying, yes,
it can get in my way sometimes,
but yes, I want to be important.
And I'm just saying that,
I think you also want to
be important, but I think.
I do wanna be important.
I think that,
I think you have more confidence than me.
I think you have confidence
that you have more to offer than me.
So, and I think that's a flaw that I have
because maybe that's not true,
maybe we have equal things to offer,
maybe everybody has something
to offer and it's not, if you,
that's why comparison is a trap,
but like, to me,
I do think it's two sides to
the same coin of, it's like,
it's really complicated.
Because it's,
I do find myself with
comparison I haven't,
it's a negative experience.
For you, it might be more of
a frustrating experience of,
I can look better in this suit.
It's like, can I look better in this suit?
I mean, I'm not as confident
as people might think I am.
I don't know, I just think
we're a little bit different in that way.
As a side note, maybe
I do a really bad job
of responding to you being
vulnerable about something.
And then, because if
you're asking just like,
oh yeah, I'm this.
If I can't say, I feel
exactly the same way you do
when you're being vulnerable
if that just immediately
is judgment, it's like I-
Well, it's like-
That's a side note of-
A couple of episodes ago
I said something like-
And I remember that.
I was saying something
about us being empathetic
and I was basically making the statement
like we're both empathetic.
We're empathetic about
different things or whatever,
but we're both really empathetic people.
And if you know what we're talking about
in that conversation, just
so you know, listener.
Kiko actually cut out the one statement
that I made where I was like,
well, I don't know about that,
because, yeah, it was,
it was at least a confusing thing to say.
And it sounded like you were saying,
well, I know that you're
not as empathetic as me
is what it sounded like you were saying.
You know what, and I'm
sorry for saying that
for the record because-
Okay, I accept your apology.
I think I knew,
I think I thought I knew
what you were gonna say,
and then what you said
about empathy was different,
but in my mind, I was
already, I am very sensitive.
I think you're kind of,
you're getting at something
with me that's like,
I'm sensitive to,
I don't know, there's
something about, if you do,
if you are vulnerable about something
or if you say something about yourself
and then you say, but you're the same way,
it's like, well, I don't know if I'm,
like I try,
I know that I'm very flawed,
I know that you're very flawed,
and you know the same thing about me,
and I do know that there's something about
this forum that
it's harder for people
to see that about you.
No, I'm not being clear.
Not that you're more flawed, but that like
that we both got equally good
hearts, but they're different.
Yeah, so I also wasn't
trying to point out-
So I just have a general,
I think I have a knee jerk
response to being lumped into
like, okay, my flaws are
your flaws, like if you say-
But I'm not saying it's a flaw,
I'm saying, it can be.
I'm just explaining why
I said something that,
I'm sorry for that like,
if I implied that you
weren't ever empathetic,
or I remember the time I was like,
that's not what I meant to say.
And then I never went back to it,
and it was difficult to
bring it up, so I never did,
but I thought you were
gonna say something else,
and all I really heard was,
I have this issue, but you have it too.
And I'm like, well,
it's like, when you say,
everybody who is in
entertainment is a narcissist,
and then you say, I, so
then it's like, well, I,
there's a little bit of narcissism in me,
there's a little bit of narcissism in you.
And I'm like, well-
And you're uncomfortable with that.
And I get, I have a
negative response to that.
And I haven't fully explored it,
but I'm like, it's just
one thing for somebody
to be vulnerable with themselves,
but then if you lump me in, it's like-
Well, and I appreciate that,
Because I just know that
we're both flawed in our own ways,
but they're not all the same exact ways.
And I'm not saying, you're
a narcissist and I'm not,
I'm just saying that the
general lumping in thing
gets a knee jerk reaction.
I appreciate that.
And when you said that you're
just as empathetic as me,
I had a knee jerk reaction, I
said something that I regret.
And I appreciate that,
but I guess what I'm saying
is, it's also, this isn't,
I wouldn't do this with
anybody else, right.
I mean, maybe with my wife,
but I guess what I'm saying is,
a lot of these things are
based on how well I know you.
So in one sentence-
But when it comes-
I could hear you saying,
you don't know me as well
as you think you do, and so-
I think, that's not what I'm,
what I'm saying is, you're
a competitive person.
Well, you're more competitive than me.
And then you see the way that I act
and you interpret my motives
as being rooted in competition,
and I'm like, I don't
know if it's that simple.
Again, if you go back to the-
Right.
And it's an interesting question
and I'm really trying to answer it.
But there's two sides to that.
And I'm not trying to
do it to make you seem-
No.
To make me seem-
Right, I get that, but
there's one side of it,
which is like, I have a
fundamental difference of opinion
about what the word 'competition' means,
which I'm trying to get beyond that
to what I think is the
more important route,
which I think as a, I sense, like I said,
and it's interesting,
it's pretty ironic, right, because
you're very open and you're
very vulnerable in general,
but sometimes I think it's like,
what I'm looking for is this like,
there's some validation
that I'm looking for
or just an acknowledgement that like,
yeah, yeah, I deal with that too.
That your response to it is,
well, not so fast in the
interpretation that I get,
and then I get worried that
the audience gets this,
oh, so Link isn't, Link
doesn't have that struggle.
Or it's so different,
so as to be a completely different thing,
because I guess what I'm
getting at is just like,
okay, with what we talked about today,
if you aren't advocating for yourself,
and I'm not saying to
exclude advocating for me
or exclude advocating for
the Rhett and Link brand
or whatever it is.
Yeah, if-
Then I have misinterpreted,
I don't know where it's coming from,
and I'm just saying, I feel
like I know you well enough
to know that like, yeah,
he wants to be important
just like I want to be important,
but that doesn't make you a bad person
because if you didn't want that,
like I said, everyone wants that.
Even people who are, even who
struggled from a gore phobia
and won't leave the house, right?
Like they still want to be important.
And it's everybody wants
to make some kind of impact.
They may have a lot of things
that are getting in the way of that,
but I don't think that's
the case with you.
I think that you make a huge impact.
So, and I don't think that,
I don't think that there's any,
like at no time in the
history of our friendship
or partnership have I thought
that we've started getting to a place
where it's just like, oh, this
is really imbalanced, right?
Like I've always thought that like,
we do a really good job.
But that's because we do that for,
we differ to each other, and we-
But it's more than just differing
because we both differ than
neither one of us would be-
You're taking a stance, then it,
you're setting me up to make
you look like an asshole
and then you're being sensitive to it
because you're saying,
listen, we're both really competitive,
we both really care about looking good,
looking just as good as the other person,
not beating the other person,
but looking just good as the other person,
I'm like, we both need to
care about both of us together
as a unit looking the best we can look.
And that means both of us
taking a back seat at certain points.
And I know you agree with that,
but you're just asserting that-
I'm just talking about
the one aspect of that
because I agree with all that.
Again, I-
Is just the being the personal
advocate for yourself.
And I, well, I still feel you
having some shame around that,
that there feels like there's shame around
being an advocate for yourself.
And the only thing I'm saying is that like
it could be shameful if it-
Yeah, because I'm saying-
But I don't think that it is.
I think we need to be an advocate for us.
I completely agree.
And I know you agree because in practice
that's what we do, but I think,
but I'm just,
don't you have a proclivity
to view it more of a,
in a more competitive way than
I do between the two of us?
I feel that, like let me throw out.
I'm not trying to say that,
I'm not trying to get you to admit
that you're equally as
competitive even in this realm.
The only thing that I'm trying
to get you to admit is that
you want to, like you
want to pull your weight
to the same degree that
I want to pull my weight.
Yes.
And in the context of a Rhett and Link,
that means pulling the same
amount of weight as Rhett,
just like in the context for me,
it's pulling the same
amount of weight as Link is.
There's a dynamic that's
different than just an athlete
who is just out there doing his thing,
competing against himself
or competing against a
bunch of other people.
It's a duo,
and there's a dynamic to that,
that I think in a lot of ways
we've really figured out,
right, because most duos don't last.
But it's not, I don't know,
I just find myself not thinking that like,
I'm ashamed that I don't,
that I'm competitive.
I don't feel like it gets us as far
as working together,
but again, I don't know,
maybe that's just a confidence thing.
That's why I brought that up.
Like, I think of that, here's an example.
I don't know if you remember it,
well, you have to remember some of this.
I don't know why this popped into my head.
When we were doing those
song biscuits, okay,
so we would do a podcast with somebody,
and in this particular
time it was Nice Peter.
Okay.
And we did a podcast,
and then we sat down and
we did a song biscuit
where we write a song together
and we just record the thing for an hour,
try to within an hour, write,
and then perform the song
based on suggestions from Twitter.
And so we started writing
this song with Nice Peter
and like,
I mean, I'm immediately aware that like,
okay, I'm the guy on the
keyboard who is gonna write down
whatever that he everybody comes up with
because I don't play-
And keyboard, you mean laptop,
not keyboard, the instrument.
Yes.
In the context of.
Laptop, I'm the guy on the laptop keyboard
because I can't play a
keyboard or a guitar.
Right.
Okay, so,
I'm not as much of a contributor here.
I gotta find my lane,
you got this other guy,
Pete is like very talented,
very quick on his feet.
We're writing a song together,
everybody has got their own verse.
We're writing this thing,
it was very difficult-
Yeah.
For me because it's like,
it's not just you and me,
and like we can work together and-
I think this is a good example.
I think, I remember like
all of these comparisons
going through my head.
You used the term 'comparisons.'
Yeah, because I knew that I couldn't win,
so it's not a competition.
Okay, I'll use your-
That's why I'm not telling-
I'll use your terminology,
but this is a great example because-
It's the point of,
yeah, that's the different point of view
between how a competitive
lens views that situation.
I guess I'm just saying,
I'm using the term 'comparative lens.'
Because I think you wanted to have,
you wanted to have the best verse,
you wanted to do the best you could do.
And you wanted the best verse,
and I wanted the best verse,
and Pete wanted the best verse.
And in my mind what that
contributes to is the best song.
Right.
Right, but-
I specifically remember
being self-conscious
about the fact that he's so
much better of a guitar player
than me, right?
Yeah.
And so, and again, is that competitive?
I think that's competitive,
I think it's like, man, he is,
I'm self-conscious because-
I think you, but then-
He is such a good guitar player.
So you're gonna step up
and you're gonna win,
and I'm like, I gotta find my lane
because I'm gonna lose.
And I think that's the same thing.
And that's what I'm saying is different.
Okay, and I just think that,
yeah, I gotta find my lane.
And then I'm like, you know what.
what I did in that situation is
I played rhythm and he
played like lead, right,
because, yeah, I can't compete with him.
I'm not gonna be better
at the guitar than him,
but what can I do to contribute
because I do have a guitar
and I want to keep up with him.
So it wasn't like let's beat Pete,
it was more like, I think
I'm thinking the same thing.
What's my lane in this situation?
One of them is writing as
good of a verse as I can,
so that, not so that people will be like
Rhett had the best verse
because that would be unhealthy,
but if people were to be like,
man, Pete and Link were
really funny and Rhett wasn't,
like I would have a problem with that.
Yeah.
And I feel like if I didn't
have a problem with that,
I would be a shitty entertainer.
Yeah, and I just felt like,
in that instance like,
okay, I can't play to my strengths here,
and it was like,
and I remember there
was a point where like,
unlike how we would usually do it,
that we would be writing the
verses very collaboratively.
I remember there was a point where every,
like we sketched out the
verses, then everybody went,
the two of you went and like,
you were working on your own verse
because I think Pete was like, I need,
I can't remember how it happened.
Mm-hmm.
But it was just like,
oh, this became a, every man for himself
writing their own thing
and coming up with how
they're gonna do it.
And I was like, I hate this.
This is not how I want this to go.
And it was just because I felt like.
But you didn't, but this is
the difference between you
and someone who I would
say is not competitive
is that you didn't implode
and not do a good verse.
You were like, damn, I
gotta write a good verse.
The same thing that I
think I was thinking.
I was thinking, why aren't
all three of us writing
all three of these verses together?
Sure, but that, to me that,
yeah, that's a separate
concern, but once given-
Because a competitive person says,
I'm gonna, this is my thing,
I'm gonna make it as good
as possible, I'll be back,
and that's what happened, it was like,
and I never had the instinct.
Hey guys, let me go over here on my own
and make my thing as good as it can be
because I know you are gonna do that.
But see my observation of you as a person
is that any time you have to do something,
you fully commit to it and
make it as good as it can be.
Yeah.
So I guess what I'm saying is,
is that in my mind there
are plenty of people
in the world who given the
opportunity to do something
in the context of someone
else doing the same thing
back away and say, I don't
wanna be a part of this,
but like you don't.
Well, I couldn't do that.
Yeah, but I'm saying you don't,
there's nothing in the final product,
there's nothing in your, what you say,
all your actions and all
your outward emotions
communicate to me that you're trying
at least as hard as I am.
And so maybe I'm interpreting that wrong,
but to me it's just like,
oh, he wants this too
to the same degree that I do.
And that's a good thing, like I,
at no point during any of this
whole, to our conversation,
have I been trying to say,
just admit you're bad like me,
which again, I feel like
that's what I hear you saying,
you want me to admit I'm bad like you
because you keep using the
word 'flaws' and stuff.
I'm not, actually in this
instance I'm very flawed,
but in this instance I'm not,
I am actually trying to
get to a place where,
and this is to unpack a
whole different layer,
like the whole issue of
being a personal advocate
and having some pride,
coming from an evangelical
Christian background,
that's something that I've
had to come to grips with
is being okay.
My wife is the same way,
especially as a woman
coming up in the evangelical environment,
being an advocate for yourself felt dirty.
And it felt like you were being sinful
and you were being
prideful in the bad way.
And that's a huge part of our psyche
and a huge part of our background
and sort of our foundational
philosophy is that
the moment you become
an advocate for yourself
and you realize, I actually
do want to be funny
or I do want to seem important.
That's all bad all the time.
And I think over the past few years,
I'm kind of coming to
the realization that,
you know what, being an
advocate for yourself
is actually a healthy
thing when it's funneled
into the right thing and
it doesn't go overboard
and it doesn't happen at
the expense of other people.
And what I hear you saying is that,
I wanted to contribute to
the whole, and so do I.
I feel like me focusing on me
being the best Rhett I can be
makes the best Rhett and Link we can be.
And I think what I'm looking
for is you to be like,
yeah, I feel the same way,
just so I don't feel crazy.
I feel like, I do want to be
the best I can be,
but I think that if we only focus on that,
then we will never be the best we can be
because we have to also focus on
like when being a champion for
when it's the other guy's time to shine.
And I completely agree with that.
The only thing I'm saying is that
the portion of that equation,
which is you being your
own personal advocate
is something that I feel like
I'm saying, yes, that's
a part of who I am,
and I can say it,
and I don't even have to
qualify it with the fact that,
yes, and it makes it better as a whole
to just say that in life
and in the context of our partnership,
I'm trying to be the best that I can be.
And, yes, it is partly motivated
by wanting to be personally meaningful
and important and have an impact.
The worst thing that
can happen to a person
is to get to a place where they feel like
they have no impact.
I wanna be successful,
I wanna be seen as talented.
I wanna get compliments on my suit.
I want all of these things.
And I don't think it's healthy
to want it at your expense,
and I don't think you're saying that.
Agreed.
But we have a different makeup,
and I think that that
confidence is a component of it.
I think when I played soccer,
I hated every minute of it
because I never believed
that I could score.
Yeah.
I never believed I could score.
The entire game was
trying to not screw up.
Like, yeah, I get it.
But I don't think that was
your mentality when you played.
You're right, you're right.
I wanna be the guy, I can score.
I was trying to win, you're right.
I will win.
Yeah.
And I'll be like, I don't want to lose.
It's just like, I don't,
I don't want to fail.
I think that's a significant difference.
And I think-
I guess what I'm saying is-
To me that defines.
You're riding in a-
if you're a competitive person.
You're riding in a slightly
different vehicle, right,
but the gas, the juice is the same.
You may be right, you may
be taking a different road,
but I'm just saying that that juice
that fuels it of, you don't
wanna fail, I wanna win,
I'm just saying, it's
coming from the same place.
By the way, I don't wanna say that,
and I don't want to show
that, like I don't wanna say,
hey man, can you help me
write the melody for my verse
because I feel like yours is
a whole lot better than mine?
And Pete's is better than both of ours,
but at least ours can be equal.
It's like, I'm never gonna say that
because that's being more of
a loser, you know, it's like.
Yeah, and I'm just saying
that I agree and I-
So I think you're saying,
you think you're as,
I'm as competitive as you
when like really I'm just,
I don't wanna be the
lame duck at the game.
Well, maybe-
Like this game sucks,
I don't, I'm not, I don't-
You don't want to lose
as much as I want to win.
I guess what I'm saying
is that I see a fire in
like a very motivated-
Yeah.
Focused person.
And what I hear when you say that,
and also when other people
say it is this like,
I'm not really passionate.
You know what I'm saying,
like I'm not as passionate as you,
but I don't believe that about you
or these other people
that I'm thinking about.
Like no, you might be more
passionate than me actually,
but you just don't want to
admit it for some reason.
Like you don't want to admit
that you want something
as readily as I am willing to
admit that I want something.
And I'm just saying that
I think you want it just as bad as I do,
but you may say, well, I
want it in a different way,
I don't want to lose.
And so when I think about us going out
and creating something,
my preoccupation is,
I don't want this to suck
and us to be embarrassed,
and you're thinking, I
want this to be awesome,
so people will think we're great.
And I'm willing to admit that
that could be a fundamental
difference between the two of us
and probably a strength in some way,
but I guess what I'm just
saying is the want, the desire,
like you don't wake up in the middle,
in the morning not wanting something.
You know what I'm saying,
like my experience with you in the world
is that you're very motivated.
It may be a slightly different
flavor of motivation,
but it's not like, well,
in this partnership,
one of them is really motivated
and the other one is not.
This is like, no, it has never been the-
Yeah.
The sense.
Well, I don't wanna be contrary.
You just, this is a strange time, right.
And I do think, so I, I think-
I just want you to say, yeah, man.
I think what you're saying is true,
but I also think that I have
struggled with motivation
the most I've ever struggled
in quarantine like-
Yeah.
And I know you have too
because we've talked about it.
Right, because, yeah.
So I'm like very in this
local moment of like-
But people who struggle with
motivation are motivated.
It's just like my pastor used to say,
there's this thing that,
back when I was a Christian
and you would wonder if you were saved.
I was like, I don't know
if I really prayed the
sinner's prayer that last time,
I've prayed it several times.
I got saved multiple times
and rededicated my life
and all the things that
you do in that environment.
And my wife struggled with the same thing,
and my pastor told me
one time, he was like,
listen, people who are
worried about their salvation,
they're not the ones.
If you're worried about whether
or not you're saved or not,
you're saved.
You know what I'm saying?
So what I'm saying is that.
So if I'm worried about
not being motivated.
If you're sitting around
thinking about not being motivated,
well, the person who isn't sitting around
thinking about being motivated,
they're the ones who aren't motivated.
You know what I mean?
You are motivated.
You know what?
You frustrated yourself-
Yes.
Because you don't have
something to focus on right now,
right, because we don't have a routine
and we're not coming into
the office every day.
I feel the same way,
but that is just evidence of motivation.
I'm just saying, you're motivated.
Okay, so all right.
All right, I'm competitive, man.
I'm just as competitive as you.
Yes, I won.
It took two hours and 13 minutes.
No, you don't have to be,
you don't have to say you're competitive.
That's not the word you want to use.
Let's just use the term 'motivated.'
You are just as motivated as me.
Oh gosh.
Wait, we have not, neither
one of us have moved an itch.
No, I think so.
I think we both have.
Who?
I think that-
I think we've learned a lot,
but I don't know that we've impacted.
I think we acknowledged
the fundamental difference
with the way that we see competition.
There's a fundamental difference.
I want to win, you don't wanna lose,
and that is a meaningful difference,
but what I hope we have established.
is it's not that like, I'm Mr.,
I want to be Mr.
Fantastic, and you're like,
I just want Rhett and Link to
be the best that they can be.
I think we both wanna be Mr. Fantastic,
but we also want Rhett and
Link to be Mr.'s Fantastic.
And I think that that
motivation is one of the reasons
that we have, against all common sense
worked as hard as we have worked
for as long as we have done it.
Oh God,
I think if we were both,
gosh, never mind, I'm not gonna say it
because I don't know if it, I don't,
I don't know,
it's like we're different people, like-
Yeah.
I know you know that
we're different people,
but it's like we're more
different, I don't know.
There's other factors,
and we're just talking
about competitive spirit
and like how we view that type of thing,
but I think we've stripped
away too much of who we are
in trying to isolate this thing,
and we're maybe drawing
too many conclusions.
That's actually how I feel about it.
I wonder how people listening
to this are gonna process it.
Well, a lot of people
would have stopped by now.
It's like, I'm not gonna
listen to these guys
psychoanalyze each other.
Well, that's why, when this is over,
we'll have an argument about
making this a two part.
Nah, we can't do that.
I think we can put a thing
at the beginning that says,
listen, something
happened in this episode,
and we went from talking
about games and then-
That's just Ear Biscuits, man.
Then we don't have to
record one for next week.
And this was a really good,
I want people to listen
to the second half of this conversation.
So that's why we're gonna
have an argument about,
should this be, and this won't be in it
because we'll cut this out,
that way they won't know who won
because as you know I'm
very competitive and-
Yeah, exactly.
See, you wanna advocate for your position
just as much as me, and
you say that you don't.
No, I don't want people to not listen
to this conversation, so I
want it to be front and center
and it should be its own podcast.
I think it's an important conversation,
it shouldn't be buried after
talking about board games
and movies for an hour.
It's too important of a conversation.
That first episode is not gonna
be as good as it could be.
It's always a risk.
It's as good as last week's episode.
You know me, I'm not competitive,
so I'm totally willing
to do what you're asking.
I mean, I'm fine with
this episode competing
with last week's episode.
It's like, you did a great
job on the last episode.
I sucked, I had nothing that,
I had nothing to bring to the table.
See, these are the things
that I think about.
I'm very competitive.
And is that,
I don't think that's competition.
I'm super-comfortable
talking about all this,
and you're getting there.
What are you talking about?
I'm just joking, man.
I don't get the joke.
Okay, this is the second
part of a two-part episode
that we have to go back.
And so that means that this
is going to be complicated
because I have a rec,
but my rec is gonna be
inserted at the end of this episode
or the end of the previous episode?
This episode.
So you get two recs in a row.
That's what that's gonna
I'm joking.
Now it just came out of my-
I'm joking, I'm joking.
So you want me to give my rec
at the end of this full long episode,
which I actually I think.
I don't wanna give a rec at
all unless it's appropriate.
Actually I think it is
appropriate because-
Okay, good.
And this is a-
The last episode, part one
of this did not have a rec
because it just continued, and
we can put an addendum on it.
Hmm, okay, I was kinda thinking
we should give you a rec
that you were gonna give,
but you can save the rec
that you were gonna give.
And actually I think it influenced
the nature of this conversation is a book
that I'm in the middle of reading,
which is like almost a hundred years old
and has a sort of a
title that's a turnoff.
And you've heard of it
before, it's Dale Carnegie's,
"How To Win Friends and Influence People."
And this is a classic.
I would never read that
book based on the title.
Well, it's been recommended
by so many people
that I respect, and I was
like, if one more person.
How to buy friends and manipulate people?
No, "How to Win Friends
and Influence People."
And by the way, it was recommended
during staff training for Campus Crusade,
but apparently you didn't
take that recommendation
at that point, neither did I.
Mm-hmm.
It's an old school book,
I recommend just doing the audiobook
because of the nature of the language.
It's the kind of thing you
probably get lost in the reading,
but it's this just essentially how to be
a person.
And just like things
like when you're actually
trying to interact in the world
and do the things that you want to do
and interact with people, there
are just some very simple,
and again, I'm like a third
or a half of the way through this,
but just like some things that I'm,
it's like everything so
far, it's common sense,
but you're kinda like,
yeah, I don't know why
I don't operate in this way more,
like if you can pray somebody,
it's always gonna be better
than criticizing somebody.
Just simple things like that
that were very helpful in
thinking about just being a boss,
being a manager of people,
being a friend and just being a person
who moves about the world.
So, again, I can't speak for
the second half of the book,
it may get really un-PC
or something, probably,
I mean it's a hundred years old,
they probably updated it since then.
I don't think, I have no reason
to believe that it would be,
I'm just-
Second-half of the book is racist.
It may get really racist
in the second-half.
No, I don't think it is
because lots of people still recommend it.
"How to Win Friends and Influence
People," just read it now.
It's like a seven and
a half hour audiobook,
just listen to it.
You can listen to it
at 1.5 speed probably.
I'm doing like 1.2 speed, 1.25 I think.
That's just about as
fast as I like to get.
Yeah, I can do like 1.3.
But the reason I'm...
That was a joke.
The reason that I am saying it relates
is because he talks about the
fundamental drive of most,
of all people is the
desire to be important.
And he's like, it's like,
remember people's names
and say them to them.
Be genuinely interested in
people because you being,
and again, this can
seem like manipulation,
but when you're a person
who likes smiles at people,
which I don't smile a lot,
it's like, I should be smiling more.
I should be saying people's names to them.
Yes, you can use some of these
things to manipulate people
and get what you want,
but he's very clear that
this is not about that.
This is about being a good
human to other humans.
And being a good human
means being interested in
genuinely curious about people,
but that whole thing about
everybody wants to be important,
it's just like, it just hit me hard.
I was just like, yeah, this,
you can pretty much look
at everybody's life,
and everybody's actions from people
who are doing good in the world
to people who are doing bad in the world.
And it feels like a common denominator is
people want to be important.
And you can take that and you can,
it can become a bad thing,
but I do think that it's
just intrinsic to everybody.
So to deny it, I'm not
saying you're denying it.
I'm not denying it.
I'm not saying you're denying it.
I'm not denying it, I
want to be important.
I felt, I felt that you were denying it,
and what I felt and I was
wrong, so I'll admit this,
is I felt like you were saying,
well, you want it to be important,
but I just want to be,
and I want us to be great.
And so, yeah, I know that's
not what you're saying,
that's what I heard, that's what I felt,
and I didn't want people, I was worried,
yeah, because I wanna be important.
I don't wanna seem like an asshole.
So I didn't want people to interpret that,
but that's why it works out as a good rec
because it kinda is based on that.
And when you accept that about people,
you start realizing that like,
oh, every time you're
dealing with somebody,
understanding that they
want to be important,
and they actually find what they're doing.
You can use, it sounds like
you could use that knowledge
in service of them and not just yourself.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you're looking
to motivate somebody,
it's not you telling them
what you want from them,
but it's finding out what they want
and figuring out if there's a
way to funnel what they want
into what the group wants,
and if what you want as a company
or what you want in a
relationship, not to manipulate,
but just to make things
better for everybody.
"How to Win Friends and Influence
People" by Dale Carnegie,
published first in 1936.
Second half is a racist, maybe.
No, probably not.
We've not read that.
Probably not, probably not.
Probably not.
Yeah.
Hopefully not.
Wow, okay.
Use #EarBiscuits, let
us know what you think,
and it's not about-
Let me know where I went wrong.
It's not about taking sides,
it's about continuing the conversation.
So #EarBiscuits, let's keep
this conversation going,
but not in a comparison,
taking sides kind of way,
but like in a, hey, let's
all understand ourselves
and humanity and psychology
a little bit more.
We'll talk at you next week.
We're still good.
We're great.
We're good, we're great.
I mean, it does feel a little weird,
but we're still good.
And I'm glad we did it.
Talk at you next week.
All right.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.